other countries have long suspected our
system was fraudulent and now Biden is
proving them right here now is Newt
Gingrich Fox News contributor author of
defeating big government socialism
note um I saw this over the weekend in
the Washington Post that uh War Monger
Max boot uh said well you can't call if
America First conservatives Republicans
anymore or you have to call them the new
fascists that's that passes as
intellectual discourse from the
Scarborough boot crowd
well I mean first of all if you want to
talk about new fascist it would be 30
FBI agents entering a home with no
particular reason it would be the FBI
picking up a college professor at
National Airport and deliberately
walking him in Chains through the
airport to humiliate him uh it would be
basically replacing the FBI with the
Stasi the German secret police as the
appropriate title uh I'm happy to have a
debate with people like Max boot who are
the apologists for a failed
anti-American establishment which has
year after year failed the American
people failed to defend our interests
failed to win Wars failed to reform the
bureaucracies failed to educate our
children people like Max boot are in
fact the representatives of a Dying
system and as it starts to die it grows
more desperate and what you saw last
night at Mar-A-Lago was the desperation
of a national machine that knows it's on
the edge of being defeated and then
being eliminated and I think that you'll
see more desperation in the weeks to
come hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else